new in theaters this weekend Toy Story
for child's play and Anna will you see
this is your weekend ticket Bonnie made
a friend in class making friends no no
she literally made a new friend I want
you to meet porky he's a spool yes yeah
I know
wasn't woody and the whole gang are back
in a brand new adventure in Toy Story 4
the toys have become comfortable in
their new home at Bonnie's house but it
isn't long before things are shaken up
when Bonnie brings home a new toy she
made a sport name for ki and the gang is
whisked off on a family road trip along
the way the gang encounters new places
new toys and ones into the long-lost
both chief who is mysteriously missing
in Toy Story 3 wow what are you doing
here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh sheriff woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this woody are we going to Bonnie all
the original actors returned and are
joined by a new cast members like Keanu
Reeves Christina Hendricks and can't
heal as two carnival toys both Tom Hanks
and Tim Allen have said the script made
them very emotional so make sure to
bring some tissues
[Music]
you know you've handled this loss toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised this movies
for you if you're looking for something
for the whole family to watch this
weekend if you're a fan of the last
three Toy Story films or do you like
when toys come to life in are nice
[Music]
enough about adorable toys because
Chucky is back this weekend and child's
play in this reboot of the original
child's play series a young boy named
Andy gets a toy named buddy and that's
it
now I'm just kidding but he comes to
life and starts murdering people this
time now its current day and buddy is
now wirelessly connected to practically
all electronics leading to kills in all
new terrifying ways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the reboot also sees a new voice actor
taking over as Chucky that person is
none other than Mark Hamill if I can't
be your best friend
no one can mister Hamels credits include
arguably the best version of the Joker
so he's sure to have the chops for the
role this movies for you if you're not
looking for something for the whole
family to watch this weekend you're a
fan of the previouse child's play movies
or you like when toys come to life and
aren't nice you enter this hotel at 1:37
p.m. did you notice anything suspicious
[Music]
and lastly Ana hits theaters this
weekend ana played by sasha las is a
supermodel who is also a deadly spy I
mean I shouldn't have to tell you more
than that but the film also stars Helen
Mirren and is packed full of gunplay and
hand-to-hand combat and a supermodel who
is a deadly spy meet your next try to
get this in Paris
they'll be no backup any questions which
way do you want most in the world this
movies for you if you're looking for
some pure action this weekend you're a
fan of films like Lucy or if you're a
show host who is also a deadly assassin
Oh a Jared this boo makes out-of-place
it seems like that is your weekend
ticket what will you see and check back
next week for another toy come to life
another one
[Music]